Ultra Violent Soccer... and 7 other Football
Facts
1) “Soccer” was once a popular name for
Football in Britain in the sport’s earliest
days.
When the rules for the sport were first being
defined, it was named “Association Football”
to distinguish it from the other forms of
football commonly played.
Within a year of its inception, this got slurred
down to “Assoccer,” after the common practice
of adding “-er” to nicknames at the time
in Britain.
Very shortly after this, “Assoccer” became
“Soccer,” which remained a semi-popular
nickname for the sport in Britain until about
a half century ago, along with just “Football.”
The game initially spread throughout the world
primarily known as “Football.”
However, in countries where other forms of
football already were dominate, the nickname
“Soccer” was, and in some cases still
is, the preferred name for this reason.
2) Frenchman Just Fontaine holds the record
for most World Cup goals in one tournament
from 1958 when he scored an astonishing 13
goals.
For reference, the top scorer in the history
of the World Cup, Brazilian Ronaldo, scored
a total of 15 times participating in four
different World Cups.
3) The Earliest Known Soccer Sport was in
1004 B.C. Japan.
There are also many references to similar
sports in 50 B.C.
China, even being played between teams from
China and Japan.
The Romans played several types of football
games, including some that resembled soccer,
one of which was also included in the Roman
Olympic Games.
This particular version featured 27 men a
side and was extremely rough, with it being
common for most players to require medical
attention after the game.
4) Most of the earliest forms of football
were named thus, not because you kicked a
ball with your foot, but because they were
played on foot.
Peasants played most of their sports on foot;
aristocrats played many of theirs on horseback.
Thus, games played on foot were called “football,”
whether they had anything to do with kicking
a ball or not.
Indeed, many of the Earliest Forms of Football
involved carrying balls in an attempt to get
across goal lines passed some opposing team
or individual players.
5) The first and only goalkeeper in history
to win the World Cup Golden Ball (Most Valuable
Player award) was German goalkeeper Oliver
Kahn during the 2002 FIFA World Cup in which
Germany made it to the final but was defeated
by Brazil.
6) German legend Lothar Matthaus has played
in five FIFA World Cups (1982, 1986, 1990,
1994, 1998) more than any other outfield player,
and also holds the record for the most World
Cup matches played by a single player with
25.
He also took part in three consecutive finals
(1982, 1986 and 1990) but only won the last
one.
7) The Oldest Captain to lead a participating
Football nation to a World Cup triumph was
the legendary Italian goalkeeper Dino Zoff,
who at the age of 40 led Italy to their 1982
FIFA World Cup title.
8) Only two World Cup Finals Penalties have
been decided on penalties and coincidentally
Italy took part in both of them.
In the World Cup of 1994, Brazil beat Italy
in a dramatic penalty shoot-out, while 12
years later in the World Cup of 2006 Italy
beat France.
In the latter final, one of the greatest Footballers
ever, Frenchman Zinedine Zidane, famously
head butted Marco Materazzi in the chest,
which led to a red card and the defeat of
France.